[Applause]
[Music]
here in suburbs across the place to be
I'm at the largest helicopter exhibition
in Europe this week and here's what's
coming up on the show
heli tack of the future I find out what
makes Airbus is newest chopper so
advanced digital detox Angela finds out
how we should all be switching off
literally and the Dark Elves are back
we've got the return of Warhammer in our
games review that's also can see you
after a look at the tech stories that
made headlines this week yahoo has
admitted that a cyber attack in 2013
targeted all of its users that's 3
billion accounts when the hack was
disclosed last year it was reported
around a third of accounts have been
affected that alone made it the largest
breach in history Apple and Amazon's tax
affairs are back in the news the EU is
taking Ireland to court over its failure
to make Apple pay up to 13 billion euros
in tax the European Commission has also
ordered Amazon to pay around 250 million
euros in back taxes after finding it had
benefited from a tax deal with
Luxembourg that broke rules on state aid
Google's announced its latest phone the
pixel tooth as well as a mini version of
its home smart speaker the voice
assistant looks set to rival Amazon's
equivalent the echo dot the devices will
be available later this year and eBay's
created a method of working out what you
want to buy even if you're not sure by
tracking your state of mind with a
headset the company showcased a
subconscious shopping experience in
London this week the headsets measured
customers neurological responses to
items so the system could then fill
their shopping carts with products
suggested just for them
so this is heli Tech International held
in London this year think of it as a
must-have get-together for the
helicopter industry and as you can
imagine there's a lot of technology
involved in keeping choppers
cutting-edge which is why Schweitzer and
I've already been getting a look at
Airbus is latest and the most
technologically advanced helicopter it
hasn't even gone into service yet we are
looking at the H 160 the brand new
medium of Airbus air copter and what is
special about this h1 in many many
things full of innovation one of the big
one is just above you it's called blue
edge blade and you can see the shape
like a boomerang and it's completely
changed the way the blades interact with
the air and then we decrease the sound
and on the vicinity of the helicopter
yes quite does not have laser no it's
the first time in the world and this is
something absolutely unique as well only
this aircraft is equipped with what we
call a byte plan so to plan okay usually
it's a big single plan what benefit does
that mean the helicopter being flat the
pilots have a better control of the
aircraft so it's slightly slanted one
side precise is 12 degrees yes Wow and
the idea is that you create typically in
hover when you offer you create a kind
of lift by tilting a little bit and you
save weight
[Music]
who are these helicopters made many oil
and gas food change you know and
platforms then we have another big
missions which is EMS medical services
then we have of course VIP a great
success in VIP rich people who'd like to
yes yes so can I get in
yeah sure what do you call one of these
displays so this is called le onyx and
the idea is to have vertical screen to
have a much better visibility for the
pilot as you can see your left eye sees
inside the instrument panel when you
right eyes it's outside France we've got
to improve safety and navigation safety
mending and you can survey the sky and
you can precisely see where you land
how fast is this travel app this
helicopter will probably reach a max
speed of 155 knots which means roughly
300 kilometres per hour yes yes this one
won't go into service until 2019 though
is that right
why'd it take so long to develop a
helicopter we are flying to prototype we
have a brand new process of developing
producing and maintaining this effort
with new tools typically an example is
two robots on the assembly line
you got robots building there yes it's a
revolution for us it's a new generation
completely now away from a heli tech I
want to catch up with Angela this week
has been investigating how we can
restore some balance into our
increasingly green dominated lives and
you really should put down your phone or
tablet or office how much screen time
should you allow yourself and your
children in the US the American Academy
of Pediatrics says entertainment media
like gaming apps should be limited to no
more than one or two hours per day in
the UK official guidelines are yet to be
released
Tonya Goodwin has been campaigning for
them in response to those wanting help
logging off she started running digital
detox camps
something that's already big business in
countries like China and the US some of
the things we encourage people to do on
our digital detox
treats are looking at mindful activities
so an activity that really requires your
focus and concentration your complete
concentration unlike a screen where
you're kind of half in the screen world
and the real world so any kind of
activity where you have to focus could
be something like Jaeger surfing
actually people do a lot of things like
jigsaw so that that sounds really retro
but actually they require you to really
focus on what you're doing creative
activities and as we're here now getting
outside getting outside the fresh air
Tania carried out his survey of more
than 500 young people aged 13 to 18 of
those 29 percent said that they spent
more than eight hours a day online
well 36 percent said they regularly fell
asleep with their phone or laptop in bed
one of the other common trends
discovered from the survey was that
two-thirds of children turn to their
phone when they're bored but it's not
just children which is why detox camps
are becoming increasingly popular for
all ages we all do it even when we relax
drinking coffee waiting for friends with
friends always scrolling through social
media and seeing what other people are
doing online so how can we resist the
urge to check in and check up quite so
often mindset coach Donna Hubbard says
there are simple things everyone can do
to help themselves when you get to reach
for your phone just pause and ask
yourself if there will be any price to
pay for choosing to invest your
headspace online in that moment for
example will it mean that you'll miss
out on quality time with friends and
family that you're not going to get back
and that quick reality check can help
you to put things into perspective and
really resist that urge and also change
your mindset choose to place more
importance on building real-world
connections because we cultivate your
life with interactions with people is
nature intended then both the need and
the appeal of being online for such long
periods of time will naturally decrease
the software industry makes it difficult
for us to put down our phones they spend
billions making sure that we don't
helping people remember what they did
before they had a smartphone is now
equally big
business Angela banned Sky News folks
like my leftovers arrived but they're
still just enough time to squeeze in
this week's video games review and it's
Simon's go in this light game studio
danganronpa v3 killing harmony for the
PlayStation 4 PS Vita in PC is
definitely one of those games as aimed
at those who enjoy the more quirky side
of the industry now the premise is this
you play as a student that has been
kidnapped by a group of robotic bears
and you're then told if you want to get
out of this situation you have to go and
kill a fellow student now straight away
that sounds quite dark and it sounds
quite evil but the game is so it's so
much fun it's so a river and it's so
silly and it continually breaks the
fourth wall but it actually comes across
like a load of fun instead of yeah like
some kind of dreaded murder mystery the
way this all plays out is a bit like an
interactive novel so it's a lot like
Capcom's Phoenix right and you find
yourself in a courtroom and you've got
to try and prove to the jury you didn't
actually commit these murders and if you
do that you'd only get to go on and live
a happy life so it's weird it's strange
if you're looking for something that is
exceptionally really really different
you want to go and check this out but
again call of duty this is a total war
Warhammer - for the PC is of course the
sequel to total war war hammer and just
to sum it up as quickly as I can it's
one of the best RTS games you're
probably ever likely to play if you've
never played a real-time strategy game
before you're not into Warhammer you're
not into total other series you probably
want to take a moment before you jump
right in because the depth here is
absolutely crazy you can get involved in
battles it will literally take up to an
hour and if you don't know what you're
doing you're going to be absolutely
perplexed and probably feel a little bit
confused as well with all that said
though if you're looking for a strategy
game that wants you to get into the
tactics and wants you to use your brain
you're not gonna find anything better
than total war Warhammer - it's one of
the best total war games
it makes fantastic use of the Warhammer
license and I cannot recommend it highly
enough but again it's not the most
accessible thing in the world to think
twice before you jump straight in
gunned down versus for the PlayStation 4
is one of those games that if you look
at it from afar you're probably going to
be really confused and think it's one of
the most complicated things you could
ever try and sit down and learn but
here's the thing if you do sit down and
try and learn it you're going to quickly
realize it's actually quite simple and
but it's a lot of fun basically a two on
two or a three on three fighting game if
you do take the time to learn it you
soon realize that all the colors on the
screen and all the numbers that keep
popping up in front of your face and
just the way of telling you hey you're
in danger you probably want to get out
the way now it's not as in-depth as
something like a Street fire but if you
are into the genre you might as well
give Gundam versus a go because it's an
interesting take on the fighting game
that we all love now obviously if you
are into the Gundam license to begin
with you're going to enjoy this so much
more if you're looking for something a
bit different I would say go try gunned
down versus
well that's it for this week's show you
join us again for more sweat next week
and in each month but also with the hot
white bye bye
[Applause]